how you doing man you okay I'm feeling
good I'm feeling good do I need
headphones I'm all right we got any more
joints around here
okay smoke I'll not have a tolerance now
Thomas never okay though it's all good
there's a safe place I'm a little high
right now it's all good B that's good
yes sir hey everybody welcome to another
episode of hot boxing I'm Evan Britt and
I'm Mike Tyson Mike we got a great one
today drove a legend man we got a legend
we got the one and only busy bowl of
bone thugs-n-harmony world I'm so glad
I'm so glad to be here I appreciate you
guys I really really do big shout-out to
AG my boy mr. Caine for helping it
orchestrate this and put this together
absolutely man I'm a big fan of Bone
Thugs I can't even hear the mani I can't
even hear the name without thinking boom
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom oh my
god man well they have a great video
today right the awesome video thank you
well you have an incredible story I mean
you know take us back to you know really
I mean when I study
yeah we're it all start brother
Cleveland Cleveland Ohio me and my boys
real young MC brains a guy by the name
of MC brains he did some stuff Mike with
Michael Bivins from new addition went
platinum real real big and then Kid Cudi
MGK oh yeah love Kid Cudi yeah
but start it started young not a real
young with me and my boys and is that
Cooley high harmony story while he died
and you know you hear at all in
Crossroads it was that kind of that kind
of life and eazy-e
he found
Nolan he says the the thugs-n-harmony
right and the rest was like what the
rest was history you know what I mean
it's of course over 26 27 years I'm
leaving out a few parts but for the sake
of time you know we got all day we got
time brother I mean yeah well you know
it was real soon it was the streets it
was early early 90s it was a place look
you get to shoot it down
Albert mr. Albert mr. Albert's -
alligator shoes with a lot of fly stuff
and now they just put a casino right
next to his old shop that must be
beautiful nice real nice in Cleveland
for ten years really yeah shake oh that
was always that was not the cute Club
what was the name of the club's back in
the day down there it was mostly the
flats and the Flynn table with some
other clubs really some awesome back in
the day clothes yeah I don't know
Cleveland that well I played the Browns
a few times came into town to play the
Browns any beautiful people yeah [ __ ]
Cleveland for my head full of Cleveland
good food good food home of Alma do
lances Lance's yeah yes that's wishbone
place right that's a spot Williams yeah
food spot out there real good foods but
yeah you know you know the Cleveland
turned me in the peep game frog legs
really I know many photos I want to
clean like I turn down a frog legs
frog legs originally a French dish I
have no idea but if I learnt it and
clean that so that my frog legs
interesting oh that sounds like a J
that's yeah yeah um southern swagger
yes certain southern swagger in
Cleveland that they seduced or downside
listen to this is what you in know Chris
they're clean them
a variety of gangsters really you don't
[ __ ] around Irish mob I'm told what
today Italian ah yeah they just talk
about back in the day Danny Green in
those guys but I'm told my minutes a day
still now yeah mmm interesting well how
did you get from big fingers got this
I'm in Cleveland's little half town and
find one of two a big surprise yes
yesterday many times many talked a
little bit about that man and come and
you know how that infused your music how
was it that you guys came together you
know instead of you know each of you
sort of having your own individual path
you know or thinking that you wanted to
go it alone instead you know you guys
really came together we're a group I was
uh I was selling dope for my father at
the time well and are you from Huff off
of ten five 105 saw was selling selling
dope from my father and my father used
to run around with late ladies mom you
know what I mean they knew each other
just in passing and then she told me I
look like her son and she told me about
her son's rap group so I went over to
his place and left a rap on his bunk bed
and kind of find out we had already met
in school and he came over to my house
and as I stopped selling dope it started
right now well that's amazing and that's
how did he introduced me to everybody
else introduced me to you know crazy was
the first one he introduced me to cuz I
was like his partner in crime
mmm like they was musical partners in
flesh and bone at the time was playing
basketball because he was a star
basketball player he went to wound up
going to Halle Gainey so he's our
athlete hmm so it was just them two at
that time and then I came along which
came along and everything just started
carbonating because you know flesh you
did two years with with an Allegheny
we couldn't pay his tuition like we're
gonna pay his tuition anymore
and then the car got shot up so he
didn't have a way to get get back up
back and forth some Street stuff we was
going through just nonsense stick you
know you go through and Cleveland and
then after that you know thought all
avenues started to close down on us like
what we were going to do with our lives
and they started dropping off dead
bodies in our front yard because Sherm
will not sure I'm sure I'm out here is
like PCP but Sherman Cleveland is
embalming fluid so that hit the
neighborhood really really are some guy
on the water zombie water yeah and in
any way it attacked a hood and offer
that zombie water you kill people how
were people doing that as a dips like we
stepped in the freezer they would dip it
dip it in the embalming fluid a guy go
in and rob a funeral home and he would
come up and he would bring the new drug
to the neighborhood this is some sketchy
it makes you stronger the bull as an ox
you are a [ __ ] you are metal you are
smooth the no pain and if you're already
stronger and stoppable the police go
have to do something to you shoot you
minimally still kill a cop yeah when I
wait to do they keep coming what was
your guys first break as a musical group
we were messing with a local guy he
owned a record store and I had some kids
at the time so I was working for him as
well on the weekends and he put out a
record with us record called faces of
death and you know we named it after it
was a whole video that came out yeah
yeah those faces of death back into that
thought yeah we were little gruesome
little dude
we're into that for some reason like
goth yeah happen to like that yeah what
I mean yeah well that really you know
death and spirituality is a big part of
you guys yeah it always has you're a
mall gonna put it in you you're the
neighborhood's gonna put it in you when
you aren't with your parents someone
else's parents is gonna put it in you
you know when my mom wasn't there lazy's
mom was there so I had someone there so
you know that kind of thing and then
spirituality just runs through just runs
through us I mean you know what I mean
absolutely all girls I think nature
spiritualism is right in your life you
start thinking about your mortality
where am I really going from here what's
going on it's almost over right what's
gonna happen from now on yeah should I
being scared she'll be nervous she'll be
sad I should fish I'd be glorious you to
be happy yeah what the [ __ ] what do you
think well that's an interesting point
Mike because right there's a lot of
people out there who don't believe in
God who don't believe in a higher power
who are you know atheists why believe
Aaron am i experiencing god I went to
all that to use a religion for my better
purposes whatever it is and then as you
get older God let you know he's hip
you know me unless you know that you're
getting older and that the reality is
that it's very shortly in the long run
exist so how do you feel about that any
that you deal with that for a minute
oh you're tough [ __ ] that goes under
yeah you go that you feel like you're
God you feel like you this and that
you're not going just much longer
everything you ever sailor know long
exist yeah how do you think people who
don't believe in God well I guess we
don't know cuz we're not those guys but
what would they say about our purpose
here you know is it just a materialist
experience we have I think if I think
the answer that question it would have
to be what you relate with because if
you don't believe in something beyond
just on a broad spectrum you know if we
out there fishing come on home
make sure
if you don't believe your your your lack
of love is you cut off at a certain
limit no what I mean is it's endless and
boundless with that mm-hmm know what I
mean so I don't think that those kind of
people are only enhanced by people like
us just understand it you know that
they're you know their journey may be a
little slower that's the beauty of God
yes I believe in life you gotta realize
that scars because in order to not to
believe this God you have to believe
there's something it's nothing bigger
than you
if usually believe that God doesn't
exist you have to believe that you the
biggest thing ever you have to believe
that there's nothing bigger than me
there's no God as me it's matter of fact
I'm God I think you know look at me how
can I not think forum bigger than me
something grander than me look where I
come from
I'm not filled I'm trashing your shoe
you know they have to be a god for
somebody like me to be me yeah I agree
with that Mike had been listening to
Manley P hall talk F Beautiful's death
is that Manley P Holly's Western murders
killed how am i believed so yeah he's a
mystic he wrote a lot of books on
consciousness and spirituality and God
and our existence and you know
everything really he's actually got
there's a building over in Los Feliz Los
Feliz in LA called the philosophical
research society where you could go and
he's got all of his literature he's
written tons of texts but I'm listening
to his talks because he can find them
all on Spotify and something he said
yesterday just blew my mind not didn't
blow my mind but it was so true is that
all roads to true wisdom lead through
purification oh yeah yeah and you know
my life has been nothing but that
constantly purifying myself as crazy
sometimes I when I when I'm looking at
some of the shows like you know Martina
time listen someone else lecture and I
think I'm Athens or anyone being
lighting do you one go any further
mmm you sure you wanna go fragrant Nega
you really sure you want to go through
you really think you're tough go some
further more about yourself and I start
to wonder sometimes Wow Who am I why my
purpose here you know I mean yeah why
did my parents was the vessel for me
coming hard cuz my parents think they
can raise children with a lifestyle that
they had how come I feel sad for my
family cuz ain't never had nothing good
in their life since I was born it all
send all this good stuff happens to me
why me I wasn't smarter than nobody in
my family and nobody ever knew these are
interesting questions
what do you come to when you think about
that Wow I come to the fact that
the conclusion always comes out should
be on my knees worshipping them render
them really nothing I agree with that so
you know that's why I always go at the
end of the day directly to the unit but
please officer I he had the dud it was
pretty awesome
look we have the gun
that's that backlight oh yeah I agree
that's why I go directly to the universe
yeah man cuz that's all there is really
you know at the end of it
of course like yeah and don't forget to
ship out those hoodies to our fans
[Music]
[Music]
hey what's up I'm not gonna give the
hoodies out sorry man Evan I'm busy okay
I'm gonna pull the chute
wait tight ship station comm ship
station right now
hotbox and listeners can try ship
station free for 60 days when you use
promo code hotbox them there's
absolutely no risk you can start your
free trial without even entering your
credit card info so use code hotboxing
and get your ship together that ship
station comedy talk about the crossroads
map it was what is that song about if it
was when when easy died it was so
necessary you know and then pop past and
biggie passed and and it became a part
of that culture because of that you know
but it came to be because of easy easy
epass away and us wanting to give him
something and put something together so
and it materialized we got in the studio
we were in our I still consider us in
our prime we were at a very early stage
when people weren't rapping like that
nobody so we had an opportunity to be
free and just let it flow and just do
what comes best us no competition just
let it flow it just came out and it um
came out amazing yeah and it 16 weeks
number one I heard old was that song
with Billy Ray Cyrus and the kid
Old Town Road not Old Town Road just did
16 week so we tied if he goes 17 then he
beat us and a beetles so yeah yeah
congratulations to that young man as
well yeah absolutely yes sir well the
crossroads is just it's like it's it was
meant to be there yeah you know it's
meant to be I agree
like I was saying even just the name at
any time I hear bone thugs-n-harmony I'm
just transported to that thuggish
ruggish bone on each ball I mean it's
just your sound was so infused with ik
yeah it was just infused with life and
you know and something higher my eyes
are like my guys are so amazing yeah oh
yeah oh my god crazy was orchestrating
that that looked that feel that
environment that atmosphere and
everybody played a really really
significant part in a good part in it by
giving each other the freedom to know
these are your strong points so we're
gonna allow you to do your thing you
know so very very a a really good time
you know I keep them locked in yeah you
know some things that have been blotted
out from alcohol and weed but yeah
there's certain things I keeping that's
definitely one of them you know the
making of that song and the camaraderie
that happened with it and how it came
together even the way we put it together
was different it wasn't like
verse-chorus verse-chorus verse-chorus
verse-chorus he was like verse verse it
was verse first course verse verse
chorus bridge chorus end of the song
yeah
intro so yeah it was just the whole
thing it was just fun
you're being able to do what you wanted
to do you know and being in a company
that lets you do what you want to do so
what was your relationship like with him
that you felt you had to give him
something back I mean yeah of course of
course he um he took us out of nothing
we'd have anything fed us put clothes on
our back
everything just loved us really really
loved us and he died really really
really fast like real fast we didn't
know what was going on we thought we
were being played like ice Cuban dr. Dre
said the whole time he was in the
hospital dying the end time we didn't
know rent what we lived in chatsworth
got a little mansion in Chatsworth had
guest house horse stables the whole nine
yards you know he really decked it out
for us cuz we were all together it was
us and then our baby mothers then and
you know our family our moms and like
that so everybody was coming in because
that was the state that we were in and
that was what was around us nobody had
nothing hmm like nothing so anyway yeah
that that's I'm just going back to my
memory give me a second but anyway yeah
yeah 12:40 um we were talking about easy
correct yeah and we were talking about
before you passed or oh no no right at
the point when he died so we didn't know
he died we thought he was playing us
like dr. Dre or Ice Cube said let's
Prince wasn't paid and then a guide
wrote yeah I know yeah and then a guy
the whole time and then I found out I
was I was in Cleveland selling dope in a
dope house when it came on TV that
eazy-e has died of AIDS it was crazy and
somebody that was there it was like hey
yo
there was a big argument don't just tell
him like that and so you know from that
I'll just because we didn't know at that
point it cuz you know I got kids so at
that point it was like um we really just
thought it was we didn't know what was
going on like nobody told us anything
and then a guy came through when he told
us to leave gave us a clue and he said
God by the name of Ed never forgetting
Oh [ __ ] Lock this door oh he
went they were outside shooting so
not forget I was different than [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] origin you know so he
told us he said you guys go home he just
he said you guys are free go home like
free you owe us money what are you
talking about he's like gone and then
everybody we were still thinking he
played us and and then that's why we
went home and that's how we maintain up
until the point we found out and then we
came back together like holy [ __ ] did
you hear what happened I said we started
because we all live on different sides
of town you know what I mean I live with
dad with my babies and yeah sure out no
way living the lifestyle dude he looks
it no I used to ask him no cuz he used
to sleep with a lot of women I used to
say cuz I was you know when I was a
little younger and you know you're a
little more naive and you're thinking
you know I'm 16 rolling around with it I
said you didn't wear condoms are you
worried I really did Mike I really did I
was just an inquisitive guy like that
and I think that that sometimes got at
him because I was very very open and I
had high energy you know like I was I
needed Riddler when I was young I was
young it's so shameful and stuff you
know man you live and you learn
damn right you know that's the best we
can do brother
[ __ ] you know if you have some idea
about what you want to do in life and
you don't know the consequences of that
because you're too young and nobody's
ever shown you what are you gonna do
you're gonna do the best you can with
what you got any crazy
no no [ __ ] you know something happened
man so that's that must have been just
insane dude so a guy shows up he's like
you guys go home so you just you're like
you had to pack you're going back to
Cleveland epicenter
sowas and then so that whole time were
you recording music Rihanna no we had
just finished yes we had just finished
eternal we had just finished eternal
that the crossroads record the
crossroads was a remix off of an
original song we had see you at the
crossroads for wall-e Oh interesting
yeah definitely so anywho yeah yeah and
it just and now found out on the news in
the dope house well selling dope well
that's crazy and then you guys found out
and you came back together
uh-huh and war began with ruthless
records so alike a whole bunch of
different people started fighting over
Heller Jerry Heller was fighting over it
easy-easy spent right right right they
they had their whole thing going on too
so yeah it was crazy it was crazy for a
while we were kind of being tossed
around mine my intentions were I was
telling my guys were free
let's not resign we're free let's not
resign and I think that began that began
the irritating part for the crew because
I was early on it like really really
early and my guys just wanted to party I
got kids so I'm thinking about masters
later on right I'm thinking about
ownership later on cuz I know that
they're going to you know get older as
well so I'm thinking in that state yeah
my guys wasn't taking they're like man
let's just party man you know let's kick
it let's have fun we're gonna be alright
we're gonna be alright we're gonna be
alright and that began my separation and
going into my own path and that's when
that began just financially I had to
eventually sue them just for my solo
rights like I had to sue her cuz I
signed when I was 17 years old so I'm
really just working on the love anyway
because I didn't want to be attached to
anything yeah you know so yeah I went
through a lot of wars but I have a good
bit of a good business relationship with
ruthless records and Tameka now we used
to go at it and but now I have a really
really good relationship right now I
don't think anything's go
on easy ease of State and it still
collects money it's still up and running
residuals and different things still up
and running and it's still moving
definitely definitely still going strong
just know new music is coming out of
there and I just think that the musical
interest has left because I don't think
nobody there at this point really really
loves music
beyond the groups that are already
encompassed in the company loves eazy-e
loves bone thugs-n-harmony loves JJ fad
loves some of the Dre reels and stuff
like that but doesn't love music to put
out more music and is what I think is
going on there someone is there that
don't like love it you know what I mean
you have to love it or you can just sit
that she's sitting on her bank you know
and that's not nothing wrong with that
either because she's doing a good job in
there for everybody
oh good what years was that all going
down wasn't it easy pass 94 95 yeah he
was first then then then Pok and then
big the big three that's the big three
in hip hop easy Pok Pok was an easy pop
and big sort of earth-shattering those
losses oh my gosh for the hip hop
community
it was terrible yeah because you know
this is pre social media yeah this is
pre Instagram you know what I mean this
is you know back when Zuckerberg was
just getting started you know this was
so it was a different time music was
everything yeah absolutely
everything absolutely death row and in
dr. Dre and Tupac and it was it was
everything music was a part of and then
four guys in sports and things of that
nature all we did was stay around each
other
we're always involved in around each
other circles so it was just a lifestyle
that when people see you they just show
you so much love they sometimes they
just come and they just I'm on tour
right now and I get people that just
started dropping tears and saying
crossroads changed my life they played
that at my son's if you
yeah so you get that all the time so
yeah was it was just impact I think is
it to make a long story short absolutely
man what was it like working with biggie
oh my god biggie was the boss he was
[ __ ] one of my all-time favorite pregame
songs notorious thugs though he was the
goddamn dawn of New York if there ever
was one the whole city gave in love and
I mean I'm quite sure you're familiar
with New York yes tough place absolutely
it's a tough place to just be in of
course it's a tough place to just be in
and they everybody embraced him
everybody everybody so you felt that
when you was with him
so all it was always in a boss format
when I would sing and then we did the
song it was smoking weed drinking it was
very cool very good dude one of my one
of my guys came in my little brother
capo rest to heaven he came in with a
Tupac shirt on so him and little C's is
looking at each other like this they
doing this and you don't like backing
down I'm just watching these two young
Lions before I intervene
get out of here with the shirt you get
the no one not so much with the shark
yeah you know I mean because be all
sorts big with your body new is big
actually love to pop right and wished
him no harm and now we know now that we
see things for what it is
who did what the story came out how did
it happen it's just like what happened
with pop that boy who went out there to
do that he was hustling he was out there
with four other guys but he went there
by himself if you if you if you're in
this world you know I'm going to try to
make you hit me so I can get money from
you hmm and it happens all the time
to where to where people want to get
assaulted in order to hit you with a
lawsuit he was there hustling and just
standing out there at the VIP right
outside the door
so he can be seen that's a hustle and if
you know if you know the streets he was
trying to get some money and I think
everything else that transpired and it
is the gang culture in Los Angeles they
don't even bring Jesus with them when it
comes to war all spirits out the door as
we've seen what happened with Nipsey
Hussle it's a different culture like
it's real warfare with no heart in it at
all so that that's my take I don't want
to talk to Mike about it for so long I
just never had the opportunity because
you know when you're friends with
somebody and you've know somebody or you
consider yourself someone a friend of
someone you know because I met Mike
three times and I've always remembered
it and he's my champ you know what I
mean he's mine thank you for the thing
is my heavyweight champion you know what
I'm your girl so anywho yeah so I wanted
to always tell pokémon I'm excuse me I
wanted to always tell Mike my assessment
on what I thought really really happened
you know what I mean and just because we
like to understand things about people
we know yeah yeah yeah oh hell yeah we
go came from a bank of chocolate with a
few men made really beautiful all belief
is too intense very intense this is too
[ __ ] intense very intense yeah well
he was living his living God was tied to
his beliefs yeah and he was he was I
believe you know you know if time would
have prevailed and permitted he would
have somehow gotten hindered hmm because
people like that always get hindered
well I mean in many ways I mean it's
different I mean in a different way with
him still being able to be here but he
was a revolutionary in the way that
still to this day like you know
everything that happens is meant to be
even though it hurts
still to this day that's really really
what he is he's revolutionized the minds
of people yeah mm-hmm I mean guys like
him he's
I mean look at the impact he had my dogs
just the time he impacted me yeah
individually as a person and as an
artist yeah like he impacted me the way
he when he came into the studio and he
would he'd how he did it ever since
Dennis three songs a day for me hmm
every time I go in the studio I make the
most of it he impacted me as an artist
and as a person and as a man you know
yeah yeah no doubt about it I feel the
same I mean I never had a chance to meet
him but just listening to his music you
know and some people like that though
and on the in the path of history
are so explosive and revolutionary and
paradigm-shifting that it's almost like
there's not enough energy for them to
last that long man just do anything
about Pop he didn't give a [ __ ] about
dying he was yeah all the time right and
he lived that way yeah he would say to
anybody okay - you mean - [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you
to anybody he didn't care who they were
how big he was stronger with reputation
about them being dangerous he was just a
[ __ ] loose cannon sometimes yeah
mm-hmm powerful dude yeah yeah that's
what I do live in that's what yeah
that's what I do it you know I'm saying
it's hard to evaluate somebody that you
care for and it's hard to do that that's
why I hear that though I definitely hear
that you know it just hurts you know to
think about yeah you know what I mean
just cuz that time in that moment in
that time it was a lot a lot of pain
going on eazy-e just went you know what
I mean we still getting over that and of
course stuff happening in our family is
just one thing compiles on to the next
thing and it keeps on going keeps on
going for for a guy like me but I do
hear I hear what Mike is saying you know
what I mean about calming down and you
know I understand where you're coming
from as well yeah yeah just ya know it's
it's really
I mean he's and he's uh he's a demi is a
god I cannot man you know you're kind of
like James is like was Oh Jaden said
he's I can't absolutely yeah 25 we'll
talk about talk about beef in the rap
game as Allen Iverson said that's a myth
Remo no it happens it happens just with
anything else it's less corporate and
more of the workers mmm it's less
corporate beef than he used to like you
used to be corporate beef you know I'm
saying you see Diddy and [ __ ] running at
it right now cuz that's corporate beat
two CEOs you very rarely see that now
you see the young guys and then you know
social media and attacking a camera and
then you know when you shock someone for
some odd reason they want to see it
again you know what I mean is that the
compulsive disorder we have as as people
so those things are trending right now
so beef just to bring that together beef
basically is surmised is that it's
[ __ ] yeah
basic emotion it's in the in the day and
age of social media to way to get
followers views views famous like yeah
at one time I'm in New York I'm in my
car listening to the radio station and I
don't know who mr. Mack I don't know who
was in New York and he had a that's how
was back yeah yeah things change
dramatically now it's just really they
call it cloud chasing hmm
you know Catherine James clout chase and
he's capping yeah you know to get people
to you know get views right you know
really getting on money off views but
you know like my kids is they're growing
up you know they're I see it I see
you know as a father you see what it is
yeah you know what I mean and then when
you're in the industry just gotta stay
in your own lane and in music you just
gotta stand yo let you see how Mike
stays relevant and what he's doing it
doesn't matter if he's in the ring or if
he's not in the ring he can still go he
can act and box top box office Scott
damn movies and things of that nature so
you know it's that - you know it's
knowing that balance between what's
going on where we're at and when we're
talking about grandfather money and
generational wealth business you get
this know whatever I realized in life so
far everything you want once you let it
go you receive it hmm all your dreams
and thoughts of money and wealth and you
know being in laying all that stuff we
get little stuff of course when you get
it stop thinking about yourself I had
how great you are what how special if
you let it go right that's because
you're not happy when you're thinking
about yourself on do you think about
this you you know you killed your toes
here in Venus you know a shame that's my
ego mm-hmm yeah it's like have you ever
have you guys ever come across a Chinese
finger trap tell me about that yeah yeah
so it's the Chinese finger trap is you
put your fingers into it like and the
more you pull the tighter it gets so you
can't get your fingers out by pulling
them out you have to go in further to
loosen it up and then you can one by one
take your fingers out but the more you
pull and try to just pull out of it the
tighter it gets
bleh thing out of socket yeah that's how
that is mmm it's that thing the more you
want something and the harder you pull
and I try to reach for it and try to get
it right it's just out of reach just let
it all gonna come
whoo yeah that's some real [ __ ] about
what yes it is well you got some new
music coming out hell yeah
yes yes some new stuff it's a it's a
dressing uh a few you hear it but you
know I don't know if you know what's
been going on but talk about it brother
we know about it no lazy he got into it
with offsetting the boys and 21 savage
and they got to jumping him and I'm in
the same group so I decided to you know
support my boy and then I put out some I
pulled out some guns I went and went out
and had a good time and into the video
yeah well I was on life and my
father-in-law he gave me a Winchester
like a 200 year old Winchester like very
expensive gun so I started pulling it
out and then they said well he's this is
his response and is this happening and
the people that love bone
thugs-n-harmony said ok I'm gonna need
you to uh you know we need to hear it
you have to say cuz lazybone put out a
like a record against the guys uh-huh
because they said they told lazy throw
up your money lazy said no not ain't
about money just about skills and then
you know lazy shows off his 6000 square
mansion and pillars and so they started
going at it like this you know what I
mean and these this is my responses
which one should we do first
enigma is the one we want to see first
and then my guy out there he edits all
my videos he everything that I do is my
guy and people were saying we found our
sound so it's produced by my guy Blaise
[Music]
yes you can see it's a beautiful piece
of music right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
she can dip it like his tall spires be
the same resolvers without a flaw
standing there beside you like thought
through the night you print out a couple
of them dog ssmf evidences play even
[ __ ] we get key and they cannot be
afraid to Steven on a big boy hit you
with the sick boy might seek Freud
culture an enigma and a cup should be an
animal Louise and I'm although money you
know cuz it looks like a [ __ ] gonna
often either win a car
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so that was my follow-up response the
first the first song I put out was
called carbon monoxide I don't know if
you had that one you didn't send carbon
monoxide legs now stalking me it's my
newest single and not when I wanted it
to be a little longer like cuz now music
it's only three minutes to 35 that I
wanted to give a traditional four minute
really good list and so on so I wanted
to put the orchestrator cuz my weed
heads out there they like that that's
and I want to go either
I wanted to cater to them it's gotta be
insanely hard now the music industry to
survive yeah yeah what's why is it
corrupt because there's somebody always
trying to make money yeah yeah yeah
because I think it was it turned corrupt
because they weren't opening up enough
doors and the only way to open up a door
sometimes is to slide your envelope in
and that's where I think it began
because of you know cuz if you were able
to just walk through it wouldn't have
been no corruption you know everybody
would have got an Instagram account etc
right it's when doors are closed this
what happens at the beginning of the
music industry I mean music began you
know because it's businessmen who see an
opportunity with an entertainer and
artists yeah yeah and when you're young
that definitely sakya that's where all
my billion bytes that's where all my
fights and all my absences have had had
anything to do it was always about
business wanting more you're sitting at
the table and wanting to negotiate and
fight and keep our stuff to ourselves
and branching out and because they want
everything and watch the shows they want
everything
my 3/5 and I really want to show before
you can do your only show no matter what
your shows too just in case you leave
the label and they would say [ __ ] me
when I own you actually slavery yeah
right yeah that's possible yeah my son
if they gave my son a half a million
dollar deal then he turned it down
because they wanted to owning this bad
stuff
I'm very loving a little bit I love them
to death even from the guys that helped
created make that rule but I thought
that's a horrible rule yeah yes bad
world I think that was done to you what
would you think about it what's the rule
that they listen sir let me explain this
you're an artist faultless so you sign
the contract with me right yeah so if I
send you're in shows you with my
organization I'm singers children my
other organizations we get paid you know
we both I get the money and stuff maybe
you think I'm taking too much money so
you want to get off my label we go to
the court and stuff so you get kicked
off my label so they say [ __ ] you so
you're going your own and make your
money you'll have to pay me right that's
cool right I don't totally you're going
the world I make my own money it goes in
my pocket right you don't have to talk
anymore now it's different you was on my
label we have a corporation in my
business now if you even go on tour I
want some of that money too oh that's a
360 I own you
you can't even make money on your own or
there's your own skill that you don't
own your vocals on your voice you don't
own your right
no rules yeah once you sign that dotted
line and they give you a couple of bucks
yeah
they got you well there's this big issue
in the media right now with Scooter
Braun buying up all of Taylor Swift's
hide about owning all of Taylor Swift's
put a smile who'd the record label that
she was under yeah but Taylor Swift has
so much money why didn't she buy it her
side knows that's her people her people
are slipping rush you need to go and
take all that tour money maybe listen a
lot of these artists that we read about
and they say hey guy 400 me after in the
million the artists don't have that much
money the artist has got the
Oh everybody think I get this much money
but they're embarrassed to say I have
nowhere near that much money right don't
even know why they don't have it that's
true big ego they want people to think
they have there but they don't the
Curtis a mule I'm being robbed I don't
know what to do be stopped I have a
little right lawyer to go to or
something and that's how that's not you
mr. Richards
he made this no action with you truly
heaven is account right now maybe not
enough to buy a TV dinner
mmm can take you out to dinner probably
that's some [ __ ] yes sir
so as a young artist right now what do
you think the best path is yeah like
what songs no way to win with a record
label yeah cocaine's like drugs once
it's in your buses in your mind and then
your blood it affects us you can't leave
him you love being their slaves
yeah you know you guys think about it 18
in 1862 a 64 we had the Civil War they
were slaves fighting to stay in slavery
imagine what a slave would do some money
he'll fight to stay in slavery to get
the money which is really lending you
think slaves fighting for the South were
fighting because they wanted to stay in
slavery or do you think that they were
being forced to fight listen um
no one can force you to fight if you
gave me a gun and five of you gave me a
gun I'm asleep i'ma shoot you right
right you know interesting an award I
should tell go die and me in it and it's
not necessarily a thing either morning
how about bringing wash right you're
like oh this is what I'm supposed to do
yeah and you don't have a contrary
thought - no not one at all yeah and
that's the problem with the young these
young kids in the music industry because
you don't know you never had anything
you're probably coming from you know a
place where
you didn't have enough money for lunch
every day you know and then somebody
says we'll pay you a million dollars
you're like my sign changed right but
has been people that have turned it down
to and are better off now because they
turned it down it's been a few it's been
a few of just you got to fight through
it in order to own your own and that's
what that's why I said what I said that
on your own go viral do it all yourself
and then when you get a company just get
a great attorney that can work out your
deal why that's what it is it's
paperwork yeah I mean you can get a good
deal if you got a good attorney that
really cares about your well-being is
this why agents came into being no
agents came into being agents a very
intense music so much yeah so agents
came into think they make the real money
your agents make you the commodity after
the trainers the coaches do all the work
Asians are coming to hey baby I'm gonna
show you what you're worth yeah oh man I
think you know instead of them what are
you playing a basketball player you got
under me another contract to play
basketball I'm ready for what ten years
around the world yeah right you come to
this commercial right here for 50
million hours right commercial yeah that
one commercial 50 million now what do
you think basketball I mean [ __ ] no more
it's true that's happening but so the
music industry hasn't really had agents
no no no it's a different ball it's
artists to label it's a real [ __ ] you
type of a game corporations do the
labels - yeah of course
everybody knows everybody the music
industry mean you'll be sitting around
right now we all have a conversation
here like he's one of the guests and
stuff for you but and you know to have
beef right now cuz he'll like that the
better lawyer you
his money you took his money bank you
may dream in others my name made him go
bankrupt and we're all in the same room
right now try to figure it out figure
out the man who took my life the music
business is vicious yeah yeah it sounds
like no love you know I'm not very
little love let's suck it might be from
love now there's good vibes in here
right of course I mean even just this
building yeah I love it I love it I love
the environment and I'm a drop did a
little recording before we came in here
it was really really nice very very good
place yeah man it's good it all comes
from the top it's a trickle down okay
Mike Tyson is of positivity that's what
I found out about my thought was
studying myself I started studying
myself and what my biggest issue and
stuff and I found out what my ego was my
ego was my like I was explaining earlier
it was my shame and my guilt and my
jealousy in my MV that's my [ __ ] ego
after shifting me [ __ ] think I'm
a bad [ __ ] all that [ __ ]
filled you know my jealousy my in Venus
you know my guilt all that [ __ ] I know
all that tough guy that's always said
that ego is hmm it's my guilt and [ __ ]
my shame yeah
that's powerful bro hmm it's really
powerful yeah it is man that can be so
blinding right you think this is a gift
you think this is something God gave you
this is just all your flaws oh you're
sure pushed in your face you want to
avoid it so you fight it you show it you
know is it your love for yourself
there's shinola by acting out being mean
and cruel to people
you shame what you may have done before
in the past and you think no one know it
comes with time you think everybody
feeling no one day mm-hmm yeah not very
often you get to have these
conversations not very often so um I
really appreciate the whole Lane guys
are big yeah I appreciate being there
too that's awesome man what else man so
where's this beef with me goes out I
mean know where it started off with lei
and then it started with lei you know
basically getting jumped by them too and
then I charmed in and it really isn't
anything at this well like those guys
aren't answering they're not trying to
answer you know yeah so yes that's where
it saddle just let's go
yes sir yes I keep it all wax keep it on
wax love that well is there anything
else you want people to know before we
wrap this thing well yeah yeah they can
my social media you mean stuff like that
or anything else we missed oh well let
me see I'm writing my life story you
know a lot of people don't know I was
kidnapped and found by John Walsh when I
was a kid yeah so I was kidding at my
sisters and myself and we were gone for
15 months my mom looking for us she
found us through John Walsh and yeah for
America's Most Wanted cuz his son got
killed so you know from there you know
that's my story that's when I walk in
and I talked to the make-a-wish
Foundation or when I talked to abused
kids or you know that's my charity work
that opens up the door in order for me
to be charitable and people to relate to
me as a person and I think that's what's
sustained me on that front as well so
you know that that's just me that's busy
bone from bone thugs-n-harmony you know
new record carbon monoxide coming out
mr. McCain mr and
see see a any on Instagram YouTube jam
TV busy ball is get that in there I am
busy bowling on Facebook somebody at
rock-and-roll awesome brilliant no thank
you
thank you for having me that's awesome
great up Mike man listen this is another
great episode of hot boxing I'm Mike
Tyson I'm Evan Britain all right we're
out of here guys love peace
[Music]